عام جيد للسماء الصينيه فبعد نحو شهر ونصف
من اطلاق اخر اجزاء محطتها الفضائيه اصبحت
شركه خطوط شرق الصين الجويه اول مستلم
لطائره ركاب كبيره من صنع الصين الطائره
التي تصنع شركه تتسع لمئه و 64 راكبا لابد
ان تدفع باتجاه طرح السؤال الاهم هل تهدد
الصين سيطره الامريكيين والاوروبيين على
الاجواء طائره سي 919
للمنافسه مع عمالقه الجو طائرات ايرباص اي
7375 كم
1550 كلم حتى الان استقبل الصين اكثر من
1000 طلب شراء للطائره الجديده من اثنتين
وثلاثين شركه تطاير خطوط وشرق الصين تجري
اولا او ستجري اكثر من 100 ساعه اختبارات
للتحقق من السلامه التشغليه قبل ان تحصل
الطائره على ترخيص لتشغيل الرسم
الان على مقارنه شامله بين كل الطائرات
المتنافسه اليك
تي 9 1 9 اول طائره ركاب كبيره من صنع
الصين كانت قد اجتازت رحلتها الاولى بنجاح
عام 2017 واليوم لم يتبقى الكثير حتى تدخل
الخدمه لكن الطائره الوليده تواجه معركه
شرسه مع عمالقه الجو ايرباص الاوروبيه
وبوينج الامريكيه نتعرف على ابرز
الاختلافات
المدى الاقصى لطائره هو
5,550 كيلو متر في حي الاقصى مثلا 8,000
كيلو متر من حيث عدد الركاب تستوعب بعض
الطائرات ما يصل الى 230 راكبا
و244 بالنسبه لارباس اما هذه الطائره فلا
يزيد ركابها عن 192
لكنها تتفوق في السعر ما يمنحها فرصه
للمنافسه في اسواق عديده حيث يبلغ ثمن
الطائره الواحده 99 مليون دولار في حين
يبلغ سعر
222 مليون دولار
الطائر الصينيه تعتمد بشكل كبير على
التكنولوجيا الغربيه بما في ذلك المحركات
بالاضافه الى انظمه التحكم في قمله
القياده وحتى العجلات وبشكل عام تتفق على
الطائره الصينيه من حيث كفاءه الوقود لكن
ما يثير قلق الشركه العملاقتين هو
احتماليه تاثر عدد طلبات المستقبليه من
الصين تحديدا
[موسيقى]
هو في فقره الجانب الاقتصادي تنضم الينا
في الاستوديو الصحفيه اقتصاديه سمر ماجده
صباح الخير سمر
طيب هل فعلا سنتوقع دخول لاعب جديد صيني
الى السوق التنفس على صناعه الطائرات
وينافس لاعبين كبار
اذا هو عندك همم انظمه الاتصال والملاحه
امريكيه عندك المكعبه امريكيه عندك
المحركات اللي هي همم
بالتعاون مع شركه فرنسيه
الباقي اللي مثلا عندك نظام الهبوط الماني
يعني هي بس الاجنحه والذيل اللي هو صنع
فعليه
طائره صينيه بس هل تستطيع ان تنافس يمكن
في المستقبل البعيد او المتوسط ليس حاليا
انا اصلا اخذ وقت طويل يعني من 10 الى 15
سنه لتصنيع هذه همم الطائرات ولو هي بلشت
بتسليم لاسيا فلسفك والخطوط الصينيه
تستعمل بها في الربيع المقبل المفروض
فهل ستنافس هذا بعد شو نشوفها بعدين
بسيه مثل يعني
بس هي اغلب شيء فيها مش يعني عندك شركه
انيوال الامريكيه اللي ايضا اللي تشرف على
التكنولوجيا عندك شركه همم جسم الطائره
الكونيك للالمنيوم الخفيفه الامريكيه فهي
بس الليل والاجنحه الفنيه يعني طيب سمر
اليوم شو اللي بيرسم ملامح الطلب على
الطائرات يعني مثلا اي 3 تتوقف همم انتاج
العام الماضي صحيح
بوينج ال همم الكبيره اللي هي همم اسمها
اتوقع
بوينكس 74
تم تسليم اخر وحده وتوقف جنبه بعد ايش قد
صار لنا اكثر من نصف القرن 53 سنه هذه
الطائرات كبيره اللي هي بمرين واربع
محركات تقريبا اليوم توقف انتاج من اربد
توقف الانتاج من بوينج لانه هناك همم يعني
صعوبه في تعبئه هذه الطائرات هي طائرات
كبيره جدا تكلفه الكراسي غاليه يعني ما عم
بتطلع الطائره صح هناك اقبال على السفر بس
اللي يقبل على السفر الان ايضا اللي هي
الطبقه المتوسطه هي الاكثر اقبالا على
السفر اليوم هذه تنظر الى الطيران الارخص
عاده التكتات او اسعار التذاكر على
الطائرات الكبيره تكون اغلى اليوم عندك
ايضا تكاليف في الصيانه اعلى بكثير من
لهذه الطائرات الكبيره من تكاليف الصيانه
للطائرات الاصغر طبعا الوقود هذه مساله
اخرى ولسه جايين الوقود الاحفوري الصديق
للبيئه هذا بعد اغلى من الوقود الموجود
حاليا
ازمه وقود وازمه صحيه هي ازمه كرونه تكبدت
شركات الطيران خسائر فادحه بالمليارات في
هذا اطار كيف يمكن وضع نسبه نمو تصنع
الطائرات وكيف هو ظرف صناعتها
ازمه وتوقفه الطائرات وشفنا الصور في عام
2020 وعام 2019 بس كما كما راينا في عام
20 21 هناك انتعاش كبير في سوق السفر ايضا
في الاعوام المقبله يتوقع المزيد من
الانتعاش لسوق السفر اليوم عمليه التصنيع
من المتوقع ان تنمو وقطاع او سوق التصنيع
من المتوقع
سنويا يبلغ اليوم 178 مليار دولار ومن
المتوقع ان يصل الى 270 مليار دولار في
عام 20 28 ان شاء الله القادم ان شاء الله
دائما